So, for example, what would the volume of the box be if these cut lengths, the
distance x in our diagram, were 1 inch long? Well, since we know that the cut
size, x, is the input for our function, we will just calculate v of 1. And plug
in 1 in the spot of x. After some simplification, we would see that the volume
of the box, measured in inches cubed, would be 15. That's pretty interesting,
but one piece of information isn't enough to figure out what the best cut size
is. And remember, Athena wants to maximize the volume of her box. So let's try a
few different values. So, I've already filled in the volume of the box that
would result if the cut size was 1 inch. And I'd like you to fill in the other
four volumes that are left over for the other 4 cut sizes that are left over.